meeting of the executive I will now read
out the emergency evacuation
announcements
there are no plan fire drills so the
alarm activates please leave the
building in an orderly fashion via your
nearest higher exit
please use either the fire exit through
the main doors of the hole or the fire
exit in the storeroom adjacent to the
stage the fire assembly point is the
island in front of the main entrance to
the building
please do not delay your evacuation to
collect any belongings please do not
return to the building until given
permission to do so by Council staff
please note that the meeting will be
live streamed
please switch off mobiles or turn them
to silent
toilets and hand washing facilities are
available in the 48 area right thank you
okay members your voice will only be
captured on the live stream when your
microphone is switched on so please
remember to switch your microphone on
when you're invited to speak and switch
it off again when not speaking
members voting will be done on a show of
hands in line with the Constitution
I will ask for a show of hands four and
then against recommendations and we'll
also ask for a show of hands for those
wishing to abstain from voting
agenda item one apologies for absence
apologies have been received from
councilor John Mason
agenda item two non-members attending
we've got councilor McPherson councilor
FD councilor sparing councilor Belton
councilor Linden Council across and
councilor Wootton have I missed anyone
okay thank you uh gender item three
minutes of the meeting held on the 13th
of July 2023
members are the minutes agreed
thank you
agenda item four to receive Declarations
of interests members are there any
Declarations of interests
[Music]
Council Stanley
a member of RTC
and I'm also a member of radiotown
council
um right um
foreign
[Music]
item number 11.
that's the interest place for both of
you
know our
um
other registerable interest
councilor Stanley what's the nature of
your interest
uh being a member of Roady Town Council
okay thank you Council Stanley
agenda item five questions on notice
from counselors
members there are none
agenda item six matters referred to the
executive and reports from other
committees
members there are three reports from the
overview and scrutiny committee
item six one one team transformation
program strategic partnership with
Brentwood Borough Council quarter One
update
councilor McPherson can you please
introduce the report
thank you chairman the report has been
with members of the executive I'm sure
if there are any questions
um our finance director is here to
answer them thank you
thank you councilman McPherson members
are there any questions
nope
okay members there is one recommendation
that paragraph 1.3 on page 6.11 of the
reports to note the progress of the one
team transformation program members is
this noted
thank you
item six to cost of living payments
councilor McPherson could you introduce
this report please thank you chairman
um members of the executive at full
Council on the 21st of February a
recommendation was put forward that the
overview in the scrutiny committee set
up a time limited working group to
determine whether payment should be made
to Residents within the district
affected by the cost of living crisis
including to whom how sources of funding
and financial amounts
the recommendation that night was
Carriage unanimously by members the
working group was formed by the overview
and scrutiny meeting on the 5th of July
the working group met several times over
the summer period this included
Consulting with the third sector to gain
their input I would also like to thank
Tim Willis our finance director for his
input and especially as when he came
back from his holiday he had a report
from me that he turned around
exceptionally quickly the options
considered were direct payments to
Residents based on the criteria to be
decided
um to be administered due to any
targeting would have taken a process of
gathering the information which would
have taken time and resources it was
also considered that if a payment was
made to arrange a residents that was it
of sufficient value to make a difference
to them
there was also the reimbursement or
Awards to Residents considered moving
who move to private sector accommodation
again the time and this would take
together the information the
administration of such payments and the
value of the grant would be nominal and
as such have a little impact
we also considered a specific scheme
targeted at Council taxpayer similar to
one operated by another neighboring
Council from inquiries at the start of
this process the other council did
explain the uptake of this had been low
so again we did not consider that
the fourth
um
method that we looked at was a grant to
be awarded to a suitable body that could
provide experienced advice and
signposting to Residents to support them
yeah this it was decided was the best
option by the working group it felt that
these Road show style events could reach
a wider audience by being delivered Pan
the district
pan District because our areas in our
district and their need very
considerably from the 2021 ons whilst we
have reasonably affluent areas in the
north of the district in areas such as
Australia there are in the who are in
the 20 least income deprived areas we
also have at least one neighborhood in
our district which is in the 20 most
income deprived in the whole of England
it was felt that it should be branded as
community events and actually start to
lose the cost of living title so to
appeal to those who may feel that it is
not for them
our residents for example who are in the
jam group Jam is an acronym for just
about managing
because a lot of hard-working families
are struggling with the cost of living
and this
um they are often quite close to real
struck struggles but count themselves
out because they're not able to claim
benefits
we also looked at um where their
Partners
um for example
um sorry I'm giving an example here
where someone recently bereaved for
example where their partner perhaps
managed the family finances and just
need some support
so we could reach a wider audience we
felt with these roadshows involve
voluntary groups that have the
experience of offering support
at the ons overview and scrutiny meeting
on the 13th of September the report was
presented by the working group
the overview and scrutiny committee
supported the two recommendations from
the working group these are before you
tonight for the executive committee
thank you chairman
thank you councilor McPherson
members are there any questions please
councilor Eaves
yeah
um it seems on the face of it a very
good idea
um the one thing that I have a question
about is how was the 7 000 pounds
allocation uh
uh basically formulated on I see that
it's from an underspend but just because
we've got it from an underspin doesn't
mean to say that that is how we've
actually looked at what that has it been
looked at how that is going to be broken
down and spent it just seems a bit of an
arbitrary figure
which I think is um
uh rather questionable this sort of
stage thank you
thank you Carousel Reeves
um Tim do you want to answer the
questions at the end or now
thank you thank you chair
um
you might be able to add because in this
particular instance it's
the proposals were formulated by the
working group rather than by
designed by officers to present to
members these were actually the result
of the working group to arrive at the
number but what I can say is there was a
certain amount of negotiation
um around how much could be available
and this was a bit more than I
originally suggested might be available
from the other spend but it now can be
met from seven thousand pounds and a bit
less than than the chair was originally
suggesting that might be needed so it
there was some I'm sure that the chair
of having student will be able to
explain how the figure was arrived at
and the sort of things that it could do
but that wasn't within what I needed to
do I needed to find any funding to
support whatever the recommendations
might be coming forward to the OU
scrutiny and then on to executive
thank you councilman McPherson have you
got anything to add thank you chairman
um as mentioned in the paper we did
consult with um third sector now
um there is a belief that the third
sector comes free they do not come free
it is their time to pull these sort of
events together
previous events have also perhaps had
intents such as things that items that
can help people who are on a low income
that they can provide for them so we ask
them what would be the Baseline that
they would need for this sort of event
and we are also thinking that moving
forward we don't know how long you don't
know how long the cost of living is
going to last
but are we
now Horizon scanning look into the
future and provide these on an annual
basis reaching out to our community
post cost of living could they then
support us with things like social
isolation in our communities so that's
why there is also the recommendation for
the onward funding for future Years
thank you
thank you councilor McPherson councilor
Stanley
thank you chairman just a couple of
questions
um how would the hardship or how would
this fund be uh cost of living from
Grant be made to Residents in relation
to other benefits that they receive and
how much would each person or each
family receive from that Grant thank you
foreign
that was actually
um probably one of the suggestions that
came forward and as I mentioned it was
not followed up by the working group as
an option for us due to the time it
would take to administer when we think
that we want to get these this sort of
support out there right away
um uh also the resources that we've got
with our staff in managing that
and also then when it's broken down how
much impact would that Financial amount
have on those families thank you
chairman thank you councilman McPherson
uh councilor Gooding
just like to
um perhaps ask
um Tracy Lily the director of
communities and health
how this if this was to be agreed how it
would be able to be managed and the
process and the criteria involved with
what is being suggested with the
events that has been put forward please
thank you councilor Gooden Tracy Lily
please
thank you chairman
um it's it's a difficult one because I
wasn't involved in the working group so
we have very limited resources within my
directive to be able to manage and award
and a grant scheme so it's no criteria's
been set no process is in place so it
will take some thought to work out how
we would best do that and get it to the
right organization what organizations
what organizations would bid how would
we get it out there how would we invite
did it go back to members so there's a
whole process that needs to be agreed
behind
the The Good Will of allocating 7000
which I can see the benefits to it and
I'm not against it but it just needs to
be considered on how we would deliver
that across the district
thank you
um count I'm a Pearson
thank you chairman just to come in on
the back of that I believe councilor
Burton and also our officer Tracy Lilly
were at the overview and scrutiny
meeting on the 5th of July at that very
meeting there was a plea for funding for
supporting the work of the Hub which is
based in megazone which is already
delivering these sort of events and
reached the communities that we're
talking about
um the turnaround on that was not
mentioned at the time but it was there
was a plea for funding for supporting
that sort of work thank you chairman
any other members wish to speak on this
no okay members
um
so we've got two recommendations
I've listened closely to um what
councilor McPherson said but also what
the officer has said and whilst I
support
all of the brilliant work that the
experience scrutiny have done putting
this together
um I do
at this moment do have some reservations
listening to the officer so
I would like to move from the chair that
we defer this item to the next executive
to give us longer to consider the
implementation
and do I have a second there for that
second that
second that yeah thank you members can I
see a show of hands as to for that
recommendation
yep that's unanimous members thank you
okay members this is um
agenda item six three highways ranges
councilor McPherson could you please
introduce the report
thank you chairman the report is in
front of you
um just to give you an overview in the
previous year's Essex County Council
have funded Russia District Council and
11 other District councils some of I
believe
um 70 000 although that may be slightly
incorrect to maybe 80 000 our officer
Marcus hotting can confirm and that was
withdrawn last year and Essex County
Council were a little bit about this
funding it has still
um not materialized they are not funding
it so we are at the moment delivering a
service that our taxpayers pay Essex
County Council for
we had a discussion at overviewing
scrutiny it was as quite a split
discussion between whether we continue
to deliver the service or not
um I would like to thank councilor cross
for putting together the report
what we did discuss at uh overview and
scrutiny were the risks if we did not
continue to provide this service even
though we are receiving no funding for
it and being a rural area and some of
the areas that our Highway ranges clear
of the moment are areas where there
could be accidents a high risk of
perhaps children walking out on
footpaths that are not maintained
properly into the road was too greater
therefore you have the recommendations
in front of your chairman thank you
thank you councilor McPherson members
are there any questions on this item
please
[Music]
no questions okay members
um we've got two recommendations in
front of us
paragraph 1.3 page
6.31 the first recommendation members is
to draft a proposal that can be
circulated to parish and Town Council
seeking expressions of Interest as set
out in paragraph 1.19
[Music]
uh sorry cheers if you've got four
recommendations they're on the following
page
it's just the um recommendations on page
six three one that I think you're
looking at the report attached
yeah apologies
no problem are we going to take them
separately
yeah all right yeah we have
um
no six three one
that was what I just questioned
yeah Emily could you Emily Hill could
you give the explanation thanks
thank you chair good evening members
um there are two sets of recommendations
but the executive only needs to consider
those on page 631 which are under
paragraph 1.3 the other recommendations
uh were for the overview and security
committee so it's for the overview it's
creating a new committee to note the
report and then to agree for further
information to come back to ons so it's
just the uh R3 and R4 that have then
been translated into your
recommendations to consider tonight
which again 1.3
um actually it's the second paragraph
numbered 1.3 apologies for that
oversight on page 6.3.1 thank you chair
thank you
um
so members
um can I see a show of Hands-On
recommendation one please
[Music]
fall please
right
and those against
and abstentions
[Music]
questions
okay
members before I am move recommendation
to
um could we ask the officer if a draft
could be provided
um
and from the chair of ons for a letter
is that possible
[Music]
I guess of course yeah we have to do so
thank you
okay members
um I move that we um recommendation to
from the chair that the leader of the
council writes to the cabinet member for
highways Essex County Council
seeking clarification regarding the
provision of
a service with withdrawal of funding for
the highways Rangers to have a second
but thank you councilor Hoy those in
favor
that's the unanimous members thank you
can I just ask what the episode was the
first uh resolution was please
um fall forward now against the four
extensions
that's carried
okay members agenda item seven call to
one budget monitoring Council Ahoy could
you please introduce this report
yes thank you chairman this report
um is for the quarter one budget
monitoring certificates
the quarter two is probably suits due
fairly soon I think but this is quarter
one
um
Tim Willis will be going through the
report
and we'll be taking any questions thank
you
thank you Tim Willis thank you Joe thank
you Council
um just a few things to to add to
elaborate on the introduction
um the report set us out the forecast
for revenue and capital budgets for The
Current financial year
um now the draft accounts for 20 22 23
last Financial year have been finalized
um the original budget for this year 23
24 that was approved by Council in
February has been updated to include the
reserves that have been transferred
between those two years so we knew what
the outcome was for last year some
reserves that weren't used what we
thought we were going to use we've moved
into this year to be used in this year
and that's reflected in the report and
in appendix one
the forecast for the revenue budget is
for uh 100 000 pounds under spend
the tabling paragraph 1.7 provides a
breakdown of the under spend followed by
a subsequent descriptions of the
variances that's the overspends and
under spends against different battery
headings
the pay award for this year is still to
be finalized but starting budgets should
be contained within existing budget we
we estimate when factoring in the cost
of the pay award as against the level of
vacancies
other major variances that are in
Liverpool include 457
000 pounds investment income over budget
so that's positive
we assume separate food waste collection
for this year and if it doesn't start
this year there will be 100 300 000
saving
um but the cost of recyclers at the
materials recycling facility uh over
budget by about 250 000 we estimate
um the cost of Mill Hall is an extra
hundred thousand over budget
um and the forecast overspend in
respective housing benefits is 214 000
pounds over
on Capital the capital programs also
included
um in appendix 3 and this suggests that
there'll be 2.1 million pounds worth of
slippage slippage that just means that
we'll spend less than the budget by 2.1
million it doesn't mean that the money
is freed up to be used elsewhere we
assume on the capital program that it
just means that it's held over for when
the project is spent at some Future
Point
um but 2.1 million is is quite a lot but
nearly all of that about 1.78 million
relates to the asset delivery program
which
um is still pending in terms of
precisely what goes ahead which is why
we're assuming we won't spend any of
that in this financial year if that
changes we can we have the money there
and we can allocate it accordingly
I'm happy to answer any questions from
Members thank you
thank you to
members are there any questions please
[Music]
counselor Gooding
can I just ask the officer what reserves
were used for the ADP
[Music]
I'm sorry Council Colleen I don't know
off the top of my head it's seven
figures
it's it's uh so it's over a million
um there's quite a lot of reserves that
are assumed to be used for the ADP
um that that reflects the the general
policy of this Council in recent years
which is not to borrow to fund capital
projects but to use available reserves
but obviously once you've used those
reserves then they're used and they're
gone forever but at the moment we're
assuming that we're using a proportion
of reserves along with some Capital
Cities to help fund the ADP
thank you Tim
remember there's any other questions
please
okay members there is one recommendation
set out on page 7.1 of the reports so
note the quarter one 2023
Revenue budget Capital positions set out
in section three below and detailed in
appendices one to three members is this
noted
thank you members
now we'll move on to agenda item 8
environmental health service plan for 20
23 24 councilor Lisa Newport please can
you introduce the report
you have the Environmental Health
Service Plan in front of you and I would
ask members to approve their
recommendations as set out in the report
recommendation one on page 8.1
thank you
members are there any questions on this
item
nope
okay members there's one recommendation
set out on page 8.1 of the report
to
approve the environmental health service
plan for
2023-24 attached to the report to comply
with the legal requirement for local
authorities to have a service plan that
covers the food safety and health and
health and safety functions
do I have a second
yeah councilor good in
okay remember there's those in favor
please raise your hands
that's unanimous thank you members
all right that item is carried
[Music]
okay agenda item nine the modern slavery
Act
councilor Lisa Newport could you please
introduce this report
okay the modern day slavery act report
has set out in front of you I would ask
members to agree the recommendation are
set out in recommendation one of the
report page 9.1
thank you
members are there any questions please
okay members
there is one recommendation set out on
page 9.1 of the reports I'll move this
recommendation from the chair to agree
the draft modern slavery Act
transparency statement
2023-24 and produce an annual
transparency statement in accordance
with the ACT do I have a seconder
Stanley
those members in favor please raise your
hands
that's carried unanimous thank you
okay members agenda item 10 Castle Hall
um
councilor Mrs Velma Wilson please could
you introduce the report
uh thank you chair
and before I start I would just like to
apologize for the
um uh amendments coming out uh quite a
late Manner and thank you for accepting
um this report at late notice I'd just
like to start to say that I'm looking
forward to Castle Hall being back in
youthful the community if these
recommendations get accepted so no
pressure anyone
um
of the three recommendations
um the first one is that uh notices sort
of diffusion lifestyle to end the
contract on managing Castle Hall and
Freight House the reasons given for that
is
um to end the contracts on these two
assets will enable the council to have
much greater control and flexibility on
managing its estate as the two sites are
currently multiple as we all know
recommendation to ask that that a budget
of six and a half thousand pound uh to
be funded from the community investment
plan uh Reserve is allocated to carry
out the works required to open Castle
Hall and there is a list of of The Works
carried out for that sum to enable
Castle Hall to come out of his
motherboard State and to be open for you
through our community
recommendation three that the delegated
authority is granted to the director of
assets and investment to finalize the
terms of the lease to radio Community
Boxing Club as outlined in the report
appendix one
um
the background information gives you all
the further details that
um I believe that you will need to be
able to make a decision on these
recommendations
um and I asked for your supporting uh
passing the recommendation for all three
thank you
counselor Lisa Newports thank you
members are there any questions please
the council's family
thank you chairman
um it says that a budget of six and a
half thousand to be funded is that the
maximum that will be funded or is can it
be less than six and a half thousand so
in other words to readdress that as
that a budget of to be funded
only
of six and a half thousand
thank you councilman Stanley
um are you going to take that account
let's take that
um that the sum of six uh six and a half
thousand pound is our recent quotes
given so I'm confident that that will be
a maximum cost
thank you Council Wilson remembers any
other questions counselor Gooding
I've just like after reading the report
I just like to congratulate you for
bringing this through to the council so
that we get not only our young people
people with disabilities and our local
residents able to bring this building
back into you so thank you for that
thank you councilor Gooding
[Music]
any other questions no okay members um
you've got the
three recommendations in front of you
um is everyone happy just to take all
those recommendations together yeah okay
members those in favor please raise your
hands
that's unanimous members thank you very
much
that is carried
okay members
um
I will now be retiring from this meeting
on the grounds that I have a other
registerable interests due to my
membership of really Town Council
uh councilor Chris Stanley will also
retire from the meeting
[Music]
counselor Hoy will chair the final item
of this business thank you members
thank you members um councilor Lisa news
Port can you please introduce the report
thank you chair
as you will see the CCTV report in front
of you members this report sets out the
options available for the installation
of CCTV in Rayleigh which I am pleased
to bring forward and ask that this
committee approves a recommendation
presented in option two
having considered the report I believe
that this is the best option available
to the committee and when we're in a
timely cost-effective CCTV system
installed in Rayleigh making best use of
a proportion of the community safety
fund I therefore move to accept the
recommendation in R1 with the preferred
option being option two
[Music]
councilor Mrs Gooding
members are there any questions
counselor Eaves
uh no real questions I just want to
underline the fact that there's been an
awful lot of work being put into this
over the years I was involved in the
working group earlier on and it has been
quite a uh a tranche of work has done
um the recommendation of option two I
think is by far the best option
um the association with Brentwood being
able to uh join with them on the
monitoring he's going to save a fair bit
of money
um also the um the control of of the
whole system and the spend being under
under District Council is going to make
the whole thing a lot easier I think
because if we try splitting things up
there are going to be inherent arguments
are going to become as to who's going to
pay for what and I think it just makes
the the bit of a no-brainer for me
really that we go for option two
thank you
okay thank you Council Reeves any other
questions
no more questions then
um members a motion has been moved and
seconded
um
that motion is that option two has
outlined a paragraph 3.0 of the report
is agreed
those membrane those members in favor
please raise your hand
s
yeah those members against please raise
your hands
um those are saying I think that's
everyone's voted though so there
shouldn't be any abstinctions
um
so for those who alternate six four one
of one against no abstentions thank you
um thank you members
it's gone off again thank you members
that concludes the business for this
evening I declare the meeting closed at
eight
oh seven p.m thank you very much